[Music]
'icarly's final episodes ended on
November 23rd in 2012 but fans of the
show still can't believe it's over the
show which lasted for seven seasons
skyrocketed actors like jennette mccurdy
miranda cosgrove and nathan kress to
fame wait until you hear the weird food
Jeannette had to eat on the show don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
give this video a big thumbs up if you
still watch ICarly
now let's check out 10 behind-the-scenes
secrets in iCarly Disney tried to hide
the truth about the butter sock
let's bring back some icarly memories
remember the infamous butter sock
throughout the show this weird item made
several appearances and it seemed to be
a popular thing Sam used to threaten
people or well beat them up when they
deserved it
seriously the number of times we've seen
Sam pick up this weird sock has been
unreal the sock seems to contain a stick
of butter and for some reason this seems
to do the trick it's by far one of the
oddest choices of an item to use on
someone but we've learned that the sock
holds a secret even though many are
convinced the sock is filled with butter
jennette mccurdy herself debunk this
myth Jeannette said she doesn't want to
crush anyone's childhood dreams but the
sock wasn't actually filled with butter
if you think about it it would make the
sock look way too light if you remember
it the butter sock always looked way
heavier anyways there's a reason behind
that instead Jeanette says it had
batteries with styrofoam wrapped with
duct tape sounds pretty extreme right
she also admitted that her fellow after
nathan kress was a victim of a few
accidental whacks imagine getting
whacked by a sock full of batteries
intentionally or unintentionally Thomas
hurt quite a bit
butter definitely sounds like a safer
choice but we'll never be able to look
at iCarly episodes in the same way Sam's
phone number was real in the 14th
episode of season 4 we get to hear Sam's
actual phone number we always hear
random phone numbers from various TV
show characters but it always turns out
that they're not actually real icarly
creators decided to bring the show to
life and actually made the phone number
work of course we won't get to talk to
Sam but you'll get to hear her answering
machine it seems like this still works
in 2017
once you dial 503 six six four oh four
five you let it ring for a while until
it goes to the answering machine you'll
hear Sam's voicemail saying that it's
and that no one ever checks these
messages so you should just hang up
pretty cool right try it out and let us
know if you're still able to call the
phone number now and that's not the only
real thing about iCarly
did you know you could also visit the
websites from the show we've seen the
character mentioned sites like I Gibby
calm nevelocity.com
and sampuckett.com well it turns out
that these websites are actually real
sort of if you visit them you'll be
redirected to the official icarly web
site
okay so it's not bad exciting as trying
to dial Sam's phone number but it's
still pretty cool
we're glad Nichol idiom was able to take
those domains before the fans of the
show turned it into something weird
jennette stunt-double was a man here's
an odd secret Jeanette didn't
particularly like actors often work with
stunt doubles when they're not able to
perform certain move or do some of the
more dangerous things on the show a lot
of the time they have a stunt double of
the same gender as their posture makes
them look similar in an interview
jennette mccurdy shared a bizarre fact
that her stunt double was actually a man
in I find lewbert's lost love the sixth
episode of the third season we see Sam
lifting Freddie and carrying him out of
the apartment we never really see her
face so it's safe to assume she had a
stunt double after all unless Jeanette
regularly hits the gym and does some
weightlifting nathan is probably way too
heavy for her to lift but rewatch that
scene can you tell that stunt double was
actually a man Jeanette confirmed that
and said she really didn't like the fact
that she had to be portrayed by a man we
totally understand Jeanette did say that
a lot of the stunts were actually her
own work as she enjoyed this aspect of a
sitcom scenes with hammers and
sledgehammers were always done by her
but in this particular scene with
Freddie she required a bit of help
nothing wrong with that she still did
awesome and all scenes she did herself
Jeanette pranked the cast we always
wonder what it's like when the actors
first me to work on a long-running show
that turns out to be one of the biggest
moments of their careers it's fun to
hear the stories and it's even more fun
to hear the behind-the-scenes pranks
Jeanette actually has the best story of
them all and we can't believe she pulled
this off the iCarly actress admitted
that she played the best possible prank
on her cast mates when she lied about
her name she convinced them that her
name is actually Jeanette Aria which is
just very odd well it turns out that a
lot of her cast mates actually believed
her she was able to keep the joke
running for weeks it was
funnier because at first no one believed
her but after a while she was really
able to convince people her name is
actually Jeanette Aria you know you're
an amazing actress when you're able to
keep up with a weird joke about your
name for weeks before telling the truth
Jeanette also joked that Nathan still
might know the truth and think that's
her actual name we have to say that
Jeanette REM mccurdy would actually be a
pretty fun name and she just gave us an
idea for our next prank have you ever
done anything similar make us laugh and
share your best pranks in the comments
Sam's remote is one-of-a-kind
remember Sam's remote necklace it's used
to create sound effects and it acts as
an awesome comedic add-on the remote has
been popular with icarly fans and you
can even find some knockoff versions on
the Internet
the original remote is known to have 93
different sounds and it also helped with
the production of the characters show
pretty cool right Freddy uses a program
on his computer and he's able to assign
each button with a new task like
changing the LED lights using different
colors and although this incredible
machine can be actually bought online
the original one is a one-of-a-kind the
remote has been the same since the very
first episode of iCarly and it is known
that Dan Schneider the creator of the
show safeguards the gadget to make sure
nothing happens to it
we can imagine the remote being
protected by all sorts of things that
have kept it safe throughout the
duration of the show can you imagine
that they use the same item for all
these years
in the final episode of the series we
see Sam giving the remote to Carly
saying that it's for her to use if she'd
ever need a laugh or a cheer whether it
was the remotes fault or not this scene
made us tear up it really was one of the
best gadgets we have ever seen the
original show was different yes you
heard that right can you imagine if
icarly turned out to be a completely
different story with different
characters different storylines and
different names well it was a
possibility in the original script the
original show was completely different
and it was titled starstruck it followed
the life of Carly who was a regular girl
and cast on her favorite TV show but
that's not all that was different about
the show according to the creator of the
series the main character's name in his
original script was actually Sam the
show's name could have easily been I Sam
if the actual ICM domain wasn't already
taken Snyder also bought the domain for
I chose e-comm but we honestly can't
even imagine
the main character's name being Susy if
this show would be called eyes Sam Carly
would become Sam and Sam would become
Kyra Sam and Kyra were the original
characters names do you think the show
would be any different with new names in
a slightly altered storyline the whole
point of the letter I and I Carly is
because it's an Internet show but then
again is that really so different from
having a TV show instead we're just so
happy Dan Schneider didn't go with I
Josie because honestly icarly just sound
so much better we do really like the
sound of the name Kyra the adult jokes
were intentional if you're subscribed to
our channel you know we've talked about
Nickelodeon shows and the strange adult
jokes they tried to sneak in these jokes
were sometimes unintentional although
we're pretty sure a lot of the team
behind the shows knew what was going on
jennette mccurdy actually confirmed that
the actors were actually aware of a wad
of innuendos that happen on the show
usually these jokes are inappropriate
for adults so it's always assumed the
teenage casts have no idea what's
happening in this case they did remember
Freddie's apartment number
have you noticed the funny way the
creators showed the number eat it shows
a smiley face turned sideways which many
interpret as an innuendo we'll let you
figure out what it is in I busted theif
the thirteenth episode of season 5 we
see guppy reading a book called nifty
shades of beige with a wide-eyed
expression have you ever heard of Fifty
Shades of Grey
it sounds pretty similar to nifty shades
of beige right it's hard to believe that
the creators of the show would make an
innuendo like that and put it in the
hands of a child who doesn't look more
than eight years old well it sounds like
the cast and the creator's were totally
aware of what was going on the cast want
a reunion the fans of the show know that
iCarly ended too suddenly and many are
wondering what actually happened we
might never find out the truth but we do
know that the cast left on good terms
in 2012 Dan Schneider the creator of the
show said that everyone at icarly is
been like family to him for five years
and when they do end up filming the very
last scene there will be a lot of crying
however he continued that he wants to go
out on a creative high note which is
definitely how the show ended in 2015 it
was reported that miranda cosgrove is
hoping for a reunion
she mentioned that she is definitely
looking forward to going into a similar
role that's perhaps slightly more mature
but she said she would love to do a
reunion movie with the cast in the
future she's not the only one nathan
kress also expressed his wishes to
reunite the cast and said that all of
them are hoping that in 10 to 15 years
the public ends up figuring out where
everybody went if you remember iCarly's
final episode you'll know that we were
left with a cliffhanger there was a
rumor of a reunion happening in a 2018
but this turned out to be completely
false come on Dan Snyder we'd love to
see iCarly the movie Jeanette's favorite
moment from this show iCarly
had a lot of memorable moments that made
us cry with laughter we can't really
decide on her absolute favorite moment
but in our top five is also the season
finale even though it made us sob as we
realize the show is actually over we're
sure the actors do have favorite moments
themselves and jennette mccurdy shared
hers do you remember when the characters
of iCarly went to Japan for the I go to
Japan feature-length movies Janette said
that during the filming of the show
Miranda Nathan and she were standing
outside at three o'clock in the morning
in the Nickelodeon parking lot they were
getting ready to be hit by the big mud
machine and for some reasons Jeannette
recalls that moment as one of the most
memorable moments from the entire shell
speaking of the Japan episodes do you
remember the possum Jeanette had to pick
up the creature and made it look like
she was going to eat it pretty weird
right
it gets even weirder the possum actually
smelled so bad Jeannette said it was the
worst thing she'd ever smelled in her
life it also ended up pooping on her arm
which were pretty sure wasn't actually
shown in the movie however we don't
think getting splashed with mud is a
much better choice for a memorable
moment Jeannette hated the food actors
usually get to have lunch on set and it
consists of several food choices
depending on the size of the cast while
most usually praise the food it's always
a hit or miss with some actors Jeannette
had a different opinion on the lunch
that was cooked for the show she got to
be a part of because of iCarly
when icarly became really popular the
show created a spinoff called salmon cat
which featured jennette mccurdy and
ariana grande as the main actresses but
here's the thing about salmon cat
Jeannette hated the food on the show she
said that the worst thing she's ever
eaten while acting with a vegan sloppy
joe and waffle sandwiches she'd get on
Sam and Cass we can't blame you
Jeannette she said the sandwiches were
weirdly textures if you ever tasted
vegan mock meat you'd probably agree
with her however it seemed like icarly
was way better when it came to feeding
their cast and everyone
seem to love the food the Cass cup
spaghetti tacos and according to
Jeanette they were absolutely delicious
although she did ask herself why would
spaghetti tacos be a thing in the first
place she admitted she ended up eating
them for way too many of the scene she
probably can't say the same for the
vegan sloppy joes hands up if you're
craving some spaghetti tacos that's it
for talking about the secret behind the
scenes fact of iCarly for more videos
like this one check out 15 funniest
adult jokes and iCarly you might have
missed see you next time